[Music]
[Applause]
contagious this world entrepreneurs
homie look what I become
okay episode number 309 guys we are only
691 away from a thousand that's just
basic math right there baby how long
will it take us to get through a
thousand at this page six years the way
we're going probably something like that
to get tooth out but today's a special
podcast because we have an old friend
back here with us Liz wheeler she has
her own show called The Liz wheeler show
you can catch as well as a new book that
just came out that will talk about hide
your children
uh exposing the marxists behind the
attacks on America's kids Liz how are
you I'm good thanks for having me of
course it's great to have you here again
uh we got a lot of things to talk about
specifically with kids we'll get into
that as well and a lot of other issues
um but you know what I want to do just
to get everyone's reactions first I want
to know if your reaction to this clip is
the same as mine okay and Rob I I know
have you seen this clip yet or no I
don't know I think you maybe I don't
know if you've seen it yet Rob if you
can play this clip I want to see if the
audience understands this clip and I
don't want us to say anything I just
want us to see what our reaction is
going to be to this video it's a very
good cartoon with Superman in it and
that's the Twin Towers okay to see if
you get the messaging in it go for it
laughs Superman saves the day again
foreign
[Laughter]
by the way this is the thing about cart
comedy so much in one thing they're able
to say things and then we get to say
what do they mean by this oh my God yes
Superman couldn't save the day wow I saw
this video Dear they said listen I'm
gonna I'm gonna be wanting to share with
the audience to see what reacts five
seconds and it just said it just go out
and think about what maybe the message
is even Superman can't save the day
today oh wow we need a book you know
it's like Lance Armstrong it's not about
the bike Wicked I've been here 911 book
it's not about the planes yeah it's not
about yeah well that's a that's an
interesting joke right there but okay
all right so we got a lot of topics to
discuss today one there's a lot of
flooding going on I'm trying to find out
this flooding that's going on all over
the world is God pissed off at us is
Mother Nature upset is it climate change
or is somebody playing with something
the people of power are they using
something to create all this stuff we'll
talk about that too LeBron James's wife
and two Associates named in a federal
ped investigation some are claiming this
is a similar story to uh what happened
with Peyton in the back maybe this is a
way where she's getting the PDS and he's
been on growth hormone there are some
stories out there saying he could be the
next Lance Armstrong who knows we'll
talk about that next uh Liz wheeler had
some Choice words about Tristan Tate and
and we have to talk about that on the
today's podcast and we got to get to the
bottom of it because it was it was a
some say uncalled for but some support
what she had to say and that's a
friendly debate we'll have that
conversation today so next uh
representative Gates okay not Bill Gates
but Matt Gates says he'll try to remove
speaker Kevin McCarthy from his post
this week it wasn't good it was very
ugly it'll be interesting to see what
happens there
uh the world's favorite person uh some
would say the most annoying person in
the world Meghan Markle almost made a
run for Senate there was some talks
about her one can you see it being an
office with Oprah too yeah yeah that
would be AOC 2.0 there'd be two of them
okay if that was to take place
unbelievable Governor Newsom did a
couple things this week that uh got
people in California wondering whether
he's leaning to the left or Center or
right or what's he up to but he
appointed a new senate seat Ronda santis
tells Bill Maher he can beat Donald
Trump RFK thinking about running as an
independent Ford warns UAW strike could
end up resulting in 500 000 supplier
employee layoffs uh Governor Newsom uh
signs a fast food worker bill that the
minimum wage for them goes to twenty
dollars that means a 16 year old kid
working at McDonald's making 20 bucks an
hour 40 Grand a year 40 Grand I was paid
I was paid 375 an hour at Burger King
maybe 425 an hour I got a 50 cent raise
from Haagen-Dazs they're going to take
you to 20 bucks I'd love to go back to
the future oh yeah so can I like you
know what I'm saying yeah that would be
and Bob's big but I can't get my money
back coleslaw yeah Taylor Swift uh
obviously her careers change ever she's
ever since she started dating uh this
Travis Kelsey guy he changed her life
ever since David you know now people
know who she is now they know who she is
because her career was on the on the
like on the decline embarrassing and uh
we'll talk about her dominance in NFL
and we got a couple other stories what
happened with Jamal Brown uh the uh you
know the bizarre response John Bowman
Jamal Bowman who we killed what did he
pulled the fire alarm right which he
thought opens doors right which by the
way everybody her school principal
exactly full principal yeah that no
that's and that's a fact he tripped he
was bracing himself yeah you know what
he would say he could say something like
look what do you expect from me I've
been hanging around teenagers my entire
life that's their fault it's not my
fault that would be the better way and
then we got a couple other stories about
Haley Nikki Haley will cover that she
got a special gift this week big food
big Pharma companies bet on snacking
just as weight loss drugs boom Finance
experts warned a bloody Sunday for
Americans and 60 percent of Americans
are living still paycheck to paycheck as
inflation hits workers wages I want to
start off with the first video and start
off with you Liz because I think it's
appropriate the book that you just wrote
so you know a lot of people around the
world and some people in the west are
trying to get the Western ideas not the
Western conservative ideas but the
Western liberal ideas to people around
the world and they try to do a lgbtq
strike in Lebanon I don't know if you
saw the results what happened there this
is what took place when they did a lgbtq
rally protesting in Lebanon if he can
just play this clip
it doesn't look like the people of the
city were happy
and so what these guys those guys were
protesting for the LGBT they're
protesting for the lgbtq community
they're not too happy about it and then
I saw this other clip and then I'll come
right to you if you can play this other
clip this is a book that's being sold
lgbtq book for children has a section
titled how how to argue with Muslims
right how to argue with Muslims if you
can click on this go for it
and they want to be inclusive how to
argue with a Muslim
and this book is gay
how to argue with Muslims
please guys that doesn't get this over
every single parent I mean this is not
just a few books this is a whole
ideology being pushed on the children
and now they're told to argue with
Muslims wow you know you can stop it
right there
why are they doing this Liz why is this
happening
it's a religious belief for them it's an
ideology the the term inclusion or the
term tolerance is never something that
they wanted they never wanted just the
right to be able to live with whoever
they wanted or loved whoever they wanted
or even marry whoever they wanted they
always want they've always wanted to
force this ideology on us there was a
story out of California from last week
where a student out there was suspended
from school for five days for
quote-unquote misgendering and I mean
that's not an isolated incident but it
does make it pretty clear that they
weren't just the the ideology of the
lgbtqia lobby is not just oh let us live
our lives make sure that we're safe and
not not persecuted that they want to
force other people especially Christians
or religious people Muslims they want to
force people to embrace that and
celebrate that otherwise they're going
to be socially ostracized you know why a
part of this I like is 74 of Muslims
vote Democrat okay kill today which
doesn't make sense to me on why they do
but they do you know it's it's content
like this that if the left is watching
just so they know the Muslims are
watching we have a Muslim Community that
watches a podcast to to know they're
targeting your community your
denomination your religion they're
targeting you now to explain how to do
that it's Shameless at this point not
only are they trying to go to Muslim
countries to bring that ideology to
their kids at the same time they're
putting in the books and it's more
things to be thinking about to
reconsider what way you vote your
leaders because the right is not sitting
there saying let's indoctrinate your
kids at least if there's one thing like
I remember the Tipping Point when Joe
Rogan and Elon Musk were sitting there
saying you know what if you want to save
the country vote Republican I just
finished a musk's book that just came
out and there's a chapter where he talks
about that time I don't know if you're
there yet on what he talks about okay
there's a part where he talks about
you know you gotta if you want to save
uh the country vote Republican musk has
been a left his entire life I mean his
whole thinking has been about saving the
environment but now those policies a lot
of people that were on the left who have
kids going to school going through this
they're experiencing the time what do
you think about when you see a story
like this well if Lebanon and what you
know they're putting in books on how to
argue with Muslims well Lebanon it just
goes to show you that when you have a
homogeneous in other words vastly
similar you know uh culture and crowd
when you come in with just a lightning
rod issue like this that is so
diametrically opposed I mean the
majority let's just say one to ten the
majority of the country over there is
like about an eight in their agreement
and in their intensity and you come in
here like a three you know you know I'll
translate the uh translate the what were
they speaking there Arabic Arabic I'll
translate the Arabic for you you know
get out of here before I bloody your
other eye you know it's basically or
before I take your head off so you have
no idea you spoke
I think my translation is pretty close
um so on the first hand is you're kind
of crazy whether if you were Jewish or
you were Christian or you were Mormon
that to come in and to do something so
you know
ostracizing on one side like that you
you cannot expect that it's almost like
he said in there to be a sacrificial
lamb so that they can get the b-roll oh
you know this LGBT person is being
persecuted in some other country it's
almost like it's triggering effect and
then the book I don't think they
understand what they're dealing with
if they thought that the Glendale mom
those Brave Heroes I call them the
Armenian moms that were peacefully
protesting and then it got really big at
the uh schools in Glendale if they
thought that was bad then show up in a
real Muslim Community with that book and
wait what happens because they'll come
they'll come out of the woodwork the you
know Muslims are not good with lgbtq
they'll take you to a tall building and
teach you to base jump
which is you want to go first well I was
just going to say too the hypocrisy of
it listen I'm pretty sure you guys have
seen it these books that they're pushing
on our on on the children they won't
even let fathers like that gentleman in
Texas read the book out loud at a school
board meeting because they're like this
is inappropriate think of the hypocrisy
oh do you have that video can you play
that let's find that video we should
watched it yesterday think about that
the pastor the kid couldn't read it and
digest this and live that life but a
grown man in front of all grown people
no children in there he couldn't read
the words that you're pushing on the
kids and and like it's supposed like I
don't understand the ideology around
like how how that's normal the kids
could read it and digest it but we can't
hear it out loud in public school board
meeting saying are we sure about this
let me read it yeah are we sure one of
the books was called flamer and the
other one was called who wants my hot
wiener it's like when are we going to
stop is it really cool who wants my
heart yeah I'm not joking Pat the book
is called who wants my hot wiener I'm
I'm looking at it right now how did that
book is like appropriate hold on I'm
telling you right now Michael uh what's
your character asks oh I'm sorry who
wants my wiener it's in the book flamer
The Novel is called flamer and inside he
goes what's his name what's the pastor's
name the pastor's name I don't be the
Texas school board meeting uh so what's
really interesting while you're finding
that what's really interesting about
that book I'm in chuku as I talk about
that book in my book because Randy
Weingarten of the American Federation of
teachers they partner with a book
company that promotes that book in
Children's Schools across the country so
this is not an isolated incident this is
something that's being promoted from the
top down which you don't even have to be
conservative as a parent to not want
your child indoctrinated with that and
listen he asked this question like to I
go I go in because I want to know the
actual reason why is it is it because
you know and all the all these Elites
are always preaching about
overpopulation is it because all those
kids that whole Community aren't having
any children and that's just another
method of us not having more people
walking around sucking up all these
natural resources Bill Gates has always
said the biggest problem to our
community is overpopulation and why not
have a whole
like generation of people that don't
have kids you want to play this clip
real quick and then Adam come come to
you go for it
but it's perfectly normal for students
10 and uh this book
details all kinds of Duo images pictures
of elderly people nude pictures of an
individual who's in the wheelchair with
his his out all these two photographic
images are made available and placed at
the fingertips of children this is
immoral and asinine to allow children to
be able to see it's not this one pause
this one play the one I just texted you
it's not this one because the next one
Pat he's reading yeah Pat no they they
do you have to stop yeah you have to
stop don't talk you have never offended
to your kindergartner yeah exactly I
just texted it to you if you want to
find it but go ahead Adam until he finds
it yeah well I think there's
two separate issues going on right here
um number one you know the lgbtq plus
piece of you know the alphabet Mafia as
they call it it's a very distinct group
of individuals like personally as a
straight guy you know the often I I
growing up in Miami and South Beach huge
gay community I have gay friends that
would always joke with them like hey you
guys do your thing more chicks for me
but I will say there's a major
difference between the L the G the B
then there's the T yeah so
um the someone's sexual orientation gay
straight in America I I don't think
that's any of our business now when they
start getting involved in the kids or
when you're starting to get into hormone
blockers or pre-puberty blockers and the
T specifically that's the biggest
question I think we've made major
enroads to accepting gays in America and
the the problem that I see in this
Lebanese video is that they're condoning
violence which is basically hate crimes
against someone different from you and
Tom made up a good point all right where
do you draw the line all right so you're
Jewish all right we know what's happened
to them Christians we know what's
happened to them in the Middle East uh
where does the line stop you know the
famous poem first they came for the
gypsies I wasn't a gypsy so I didn't say
anything then they came for the Jews I
didn't say anything then they came for
the ukrainians and then they came for me
the silence no one was there to say
anything so
as much as I'm like
hey I understand the agenda that's going
on here as specifically in the T
Community what is a man what is a woman
well it's been pretty freaking clear
forever but that's being different but
gay people have been around forever
lesbians have been around forever so
it's a little disconcerting to see
what's going on specifically in Lebanon
final point you know it's kind of like
the Lebanese versus the lesbians we all
know that the Middle East I think
Lebanon is the angriest country in the
world yup literally turkey is number two
and then Armenia is number three shout
out to the Middle East but going deeper
in Lebanon like if you want to go you
know
the c word conspir you know that whole
word that there's a bigger issue at play
here um because
just like you know I don't you know
America gets criticized for having
regime change or trying to topple
regimes or indoctrinate our values into
the Eastern World we're not doing that
in Lebanon they're doing their thing
they they they you know they're called
the the Paris of the Middle East but
they do have a major faction in their
country that is run by extremists which
is known as Hezbollah so the the
cultural Wars that's happening there
some say that there's a major that
they've been trying to elect the
president for a year there's political
headwinds going on there's economic
major crisis going on and some say that
the people of power especially the
right-wing extremists are using this
attack on the LGBT community to
basically divert attention from the real
problems that are going on and that
situation right there obviously nobody
here obviously condones any type of
violence with anything if you're gay
that's nobody cares but notice Adam look
at how crazy that we've gotten right now
that attitude there which I'm not
condoning but you know that's called
nipping it in the butt because once once
that starts then it's the the schools
and the books and the kids and the guess
what guess what's not going to happen by
the way that's a regular Tuesday that's
only around 10 years what is the time
that's a an FYI there's a reason when I
asked a question I said why do uh
Muslims move to Christian countries to
raise their families but Christians
don't move to Muslim countries to raise
their families that's a question that we
had on the debate here very valid
question and that's one of the reasons
okay well because but I will tell you
one of the parts that you don't have to
worry about where they stand they don't
compromise what they stand for they're
Straight Up This Is Us you don't like it
you can you can take me to jail you can
do this you can do that I'm not I'm not
sitting for something like this I want
you to watch this video play this clip
real quick play this quick
because this is the one it's called It's
Perfectly Normal I'll read some of this
for you it says
right it becomes moist and slippery and
the clitoris becomes hard
can we sir I'm sorry I wasn't something
I said
watch your children be able to check it
out
why does it bother you yes or no you
can't answer that question you wonder
why because politically speaking you
can't say that it's wrong and you don't
want me to read the filth because it
exposes the truth how dare you tell me
to stop reading it if you don't want to
hear it why should the children have to
see it Pastor your time is yeah thank
you oh man I love that guy thank you
Jesus
why Liz Liz's book is so important
because it is all about the kids yeah
right like my biggest thing with the
alphabet Mafia specifically the T stuff
is two things it's stay away from the
kids and stop grown ass men being in
woman Sports I don't think that's too
hard to ask you you have a child I do
and I know that's a major concern of
yours but once someone's 18 they can
make their own decisions
I mean to a certain extent I would
probably argue that that's medical
malpractice since it's not treating you
can identify however you want you can't
force other people
on video I want to comment on the
Lebanon video for a second because
there's a reason that that's going viral
in the United States on social media
it's because that doesn't often happen
here in the United States as the lgbtqia
lobby and I understand your argument
separating the two but for all intents
and purposes gay people and lesbians and
bisexual people have not disconnected
themselves from this Lobby you can argue
that the transgender Lobby has latched
on to what they have accomplished but
they haven't they haven't severed that
and said hey we're going to be separate
except for the uh what are they called
turfs the trans exclusionary radical
feminists who are never even heard that
there were like the lesbians that are
like wait a second wait a second all of
our women's rights are erased if there's
transgender stuff but the reason that
video from Lebanon went viral here in
the United States is because that's
actually very uncommon and the other
side the lgbtqia lobby wants us to think
of any criticism or any any parental
objection to The Graphic stuff being
taught to our children they want us to
think that that leads immediately to
violence but let me tell you about one
of the things that I had to read in the
course of researching this book this was
the most disturbing thing I ever read
and we all work in the news we read
disturbing things all the time I read
the founding document of queer Theory
which is just like we learned a couple
years ago that when black children are
told they're oppressed and white
children are told they're racist we
realized oh that's the principles of
critical race Theory right we saw what
was being taught before we recognized
what its origin was well the same with
the transgender ideology the stuff about
gender being a spectrum being
disconnected from biological sex that
you are what you identify that's not
just a random assortment of nonsense
that is those are the principles of
queer Theory it's also in Neil Marx's
Theory like critical race Theory so when
I'm writing about this I thought well I
should read the founding document I
should read The Source documents to see
what they believe what they want to
happen what they want to teach children
what their goal is with this Theory
because this has become so prevalent in
the last really eight years since 2015.
so I pull up this document it was
written by a woman named Gail Rubin
she's alive and well in our country
today she founded some lesbian bondage
clubs in San Francisco but she's in
Academia now she wrote an essay called
thinking sex which like I said is is the
founding document of queer Theory and in
this document she not only lays out
these principles that gender is a
spectrum that you can be a boy if you
want to be a boy she actively defends
child pornography
she defends outright pedophilia and
tells people that we as a yeah there it
is thinking sex that we as a society
will regret imprisoning the quote men
who love underage boys pedophiles within
20 years and she men who love underage
Youth and advocates for the
sexualization of children so what we're
seeing in the School classrooms when we
see these graphic books this is their
goal it's not inclusion it's not
tolerance it's not oh your sexual
orientation doesn't Define who you are
you're much more than what you're
sexually attracted to this is their
ultimate goal and if we don't listen to
what they say and believe them then our
children are going to be Liz thank you
for pointing this out I had Rob real
quick just take find a picture of her
slash yeah that guy so that's her that's
what is that yeah she's a she's a
lesbian yeah that's a woman Gail Rubin
is this a porn can we see some other
images
she works at McDonald's go back to that
picture with the vest yeah blue shirt
does it not look like is that a fast
food I mean if you didn't tell me
straight up that that was a woman I
would I there's a high likelihood I
think that was just a fat ugly dude
sorry she's not even transgender to my
knowledge I mean
go back to the thinking sex actually
four years old so that's not what they
say about child pornography
February 1977 shortly after day County
vote a sudden concern with child
pornography swept the national media in
May Chicago Tribune ran a lurid fourth
day series with three inch headlines uh
Rob if you're on it I actually can't
read it yeah three inch headlines which
claim to expose a national Vice range of
organized to lower your young boys into
prostitution pornography which section
do you want us to read it's a little bit
further down she excuses this she makes
it seem like that this is a Witch Hunt
against people that possess this and
it's their their First Amendment right
to possess images that depict the sexual
abuse of the laws partners and children
yeah the laws produced by the child porn
pandemic or ill-conceived child
corrected well just to be clear Liz
because I want to represent far-reaching
alterations in the regulation of sexual
behavior and a broke abrogate important
sexual civil liberties like you have the
civil liberties to possess child
pornography hardly anyone notice as they
swept through Congress and State
legislatures with the exception of the
North American man boy love Association
Americans
which by the way is a pedophile it's a
lobbyist for pedophile pedophilia or
it's it's not they don't call them that
anymore it's minor attracted person
that's just their way of sanitizing but
it's shocking to you this is absurd this
should be illegal this is disgusting all
iterations of that you saw a Sound of
Silence I assume sound of Freedom sound
of Freedom okay Sound of Silence Parts I
was like no I didn't what is that
Silence of the Lamb
Chicago
freedom
that's my old friend you know no clarius
very hard to watch
I don't think other than these actual
freak shows nobody's advocating for
anything with minors I actually just
found out recently because of Russell
Brand that you know the average age of
consent in the United States
it's actually 16 in 35 States I had no
idea okay because he was accused of
doing something that was in the UK that
he was accused correct so I went down
the rabbit hole and I said is 16 illegal
it's actually not in the UK now I'm not
trying to hang out with high school
girls but in most States it actually is
16 in the United States right but that's
not what they're talking about here I
I'm fully endorsing that the books that
we were the books that I was reading
from those people are academic
academically and ideologically in line
in alignment with queer Theory it's not
just oh this is some freak Show paper
that I pulled from some random academic
if you look on her Wikipedia page she is
credited as writing the founding
document of queer Theory that's what
this is she's like she's like the
Kimberly Crenshaw Derek Bell of critical
race Theory like she's the origin of it
you know the thing that you said hey I
watched them beat these guys up and then
boom what was the quote that you were
saying you were and Tom kind of finished
the code with you yours
because then they came for the Jews for
the children that quote applies to what
she's saying what she's saying is you're
like well give me a break it's just
they're gay it's just they leave them
alone what's the big deal and then all
of a sudden you get married and you have
kids and your three-year-old kid comes
home one day from school and she's like
wait a minute no no I'm putting my foot
down and then it's too late so the the
the the the part that uh the people who
are experiencing this pain the most and
I want to go to the next story but I
want to say final thoughts here before
we go to the next door we're going to
get a chance at the end as well for you
to kind of tell us more about the book I
wanted to start off with the story and
Rob let's put the link below for people
that want to buy her book you can go
pick up her book the link will be in the
description here's here's what I was
thinking about the other day when you
watch strikes who typically strikes
you see the workers right Union Workers
United Auto Workers go on a strike
writers Gill you know go on a strike
actors go on a strike right all these
workers going on a strike when have you
seen parents go on a strike I don't
understand this here's I'm telling you I
have a suggestion parents I'm going to
keep talking about this until somebody
takes the lead on this and screams it
off the top of their lungs and then they
do it I would love to see a one-month
parent strikes 1 million kids in America
for one street pull them out of public
school pull them out of public school
for one month yeah and what I would do
is out of those million kids that are
being taken out
find out how many of those parents how
many of those kids parents are teachers
okay where the where parents can
actually teach a certain course Zoom so
what you need to do is a million divided
by what let's just say it's a million
divided by how many kids per Zoom how
many zooms can we have uh uh uh per
classroom they do group homeschooling
side 15 or so when it's like you teach
politics to 15 homeschool so let's just
say 20. Okay so a million 20 it's what
five thousand is that how many we need
is it five thousand or fifty thousand on
uh we need fifty thousand right so if
you got 20 you got 50 000 parents 20 to
1 if you got 50 000 parents that say
I'll teach a class for one month no
problem why don't we do that okay you
take one month of your salary say four
grand a month six grand a month five
grand a month no problem we'll fund it
you go take one month off parents if
you're that upset about this why don't
you take a one month strike okay flip it
on everybody else it's constantly the
workers going on the strike how about
for once customers going on a strike and
here the customers who the parent yep
parents taking their kids to school as a
customer okay parents why do we go on a
one-month strike in a sense we're doing
a lot of parents have been doing that I
mean the number of homeschoolers in the
last three years have like tripled
there's like five million homeschooling
schoolers compared to what are you
talking about you're talking about like
a month movement like a like a child
pride month everybody we shut it down
but but what what the homeschoolers are
doing is they're making a choice to
protect their families they're not
they're not doing a rally cry for others
to join a strike type of a thing to do a
strike it's got to be a unified group
coming together saying guys for the
month of November we're taking one month
we're taking our kids out of school for
one month okay and come join our home
school and come do something like this
one month let's get out let's show
America how united we are and then let's
bring the governors of those states to a
place a ring no you have to listen to
what's in the book no you have to hear
what's going on no you we are not
putting them back in school until you
change it no problem hey you know what
you did government here's the biggest
mistake the government did and by the
way let me tell you why I believe this
is possible do you remember when
uh uh companies like Twitter came out
and they said well you know at Twitter
we have made a decision you can work
from home for the rest of your life yeah
and also that's a guy's terrible I
just say that you should have never said
that please come back well you sent me
four days a week so so what happened was
what covet did the best thing covert did
covet taught parents we could actually
homeschool yeah covid was actually
terrible for public schools to realize
holy if these parents realize they
don't need us we're going to be in deep
trouble well guess what parents you
don't why don't we do one million kid
strike okay one million kid strike for
30 days and then let them feel the pain
then they have to adjust schools are
going to be like wait a minute where the
hell are these we can't be doing
something like we're not hitting our
numbers we're not doing this we're not
doing that and by the way
well you know what if it hurts their GPA
what if it hurts this whatever said at
this point of the game quite frankly as
if going to college was the same value
it was 30 years ago the same the thing
they were teaching 30 years ago the same
thing they're teaching today if you
ain't doing stem anyways why do you care
about it let's really disrupt the
educational system unless if your kids
are not going to become a doctor a
lawyer a engineer this this that forget
about it let's do this let's get them to
realize you're in charge to people and
let's get some movement going if you
really want to save it you have to get
your hands dirty because think about it
if you can't read the book out loud at a
school board meeting or you can't so I'm
a school board meeting without the FBI
labeling you a domestic terrorist I'm
like I'm I say this all the time it's
time to it's five five or five you gotta
get dirty get dirty here's the thing we
have to have an objective though if we
do this it can't just be a protest there
has to be a concrete change that we're
able to articulate that we want to
happen in the schools or else it'll just
very quickly fall back and let me tell
you this this was so interesting so
public schooling in our country wasn't
even mandatory until 1852 which isn't
that long ago and the reason it became
mandatory Massachusetts was the first
state to make it mandatory and it became
mandatory because there was an influx of
immigrants to our country at the time
particularly Catholic immigrants and the
Protestant politicians in charge of
Massachusetts wanted to indoctrinate
these immigrant children in American
values so they'd be loyal to America
First rather than the country of their
birth and they wanted to indoctrinate
them in Protestant values because of the
centuries-long battle between
Protestants and Catholics and I was
researching this as part of my book and
I realized well our education system
actually is intended to be an
indoctrination Center we think of
indoctrination negatively just because
of what the left is indoctrinating but
it's actually a very like nebulous
morally morally neutral concept it
depends on what's being indoctrinated
but sometime between when it became
compulsory and now Republicans lost
sight of that and started treating it as
this neutral institution where we just
teach reading writing and arithmetic I
would argue that when you have children
under your care for eight hours a day
there's no way a that you can just
interact in a value-neutral way you are
going to be imparting some kind of
values and if we are going to do
something like a million parent or a
million child strike we have to call for
fundamental changes to the education
system which means taking it back to
teaching American values in
judeo-christian morals otherwise if our
values aren't predominant in this
institution the Democrats values well
Liz we wouldn't tell people to take
strike for the hell of it obviously
there would be an agenda behind doing
something like that but what I'm saying
is for us to realize what things we have
in common right now one is our
conservative values that have
disappeared okay we've taken we're
afraid of prayer for whatever reason but
we're not afraid of lgbtq stuff being
taught in school very confusing for me
and when it comes down to certain things
that's being taught right now if we can
unify around three things someone needs
to take the lead make a website write
down five things we're demanding and ask
him to change go on a one-month strike
get people to volunteer let's pick the
dates on when it's going to happen let
people feel the pain if we are
supporting unions going on strike and
destroying businesses great why don't we
do the same thing to you the biggest
Union in America is Teachers Union the
biggest Union in America's teachers unit
let's let them feel the pain a little
bit hey guys you keep trying to bully
all of our kids hey let us kind of give
you a little bit of taste of your
medicine and we've never done this
before I think I think the parents show
during covet you can actually pull this
off let's go to the next story okay
all these flooding that's going on okay
we're seeing it all over the world New
York terrible situation right you got
Libya I'll read a couple of these
stories here climate change and NYC
historic rain Buckle City's
infrastructure again this is an NBC
story talking about uh severe storm with
over seven inches of rain and less than
24 hours wreaks havoc in New York City
Rob if you can find a video without
audio to just play it inundating streets
and crippling transportation system
highlighting the city's vulnerability to
climate change driven extreme weather
that part is very that is that's New
York yeah people were walking in there
yeah I mean it just doesn't make any car
yeah it doesn't make any sense and then
by the way another one here in Las Vegas
after historic flooding what's next for
recreation of Mount Charleston okay in
August 21st a historic flood caused
tropical storm Hillary devastated Mount
Charleston Nevada can you go to that one
right there if you can find a video on
Mount Charleston uh best name Nevada
flood best hurricane with eight inches
of rainfall in 48 hours damage in homes
buildings and structure although no
injuries reported then this is Nevada by
the way which makes no sense and then
you have Libya which is the most tragic
one Libya flooding that's up to 11 000
tops 11 000 as thousands reported
missing the death toll for the
catastrophic floods in eastern Libya has
climbed to 11 000 with nearly 4 000
bodies recovered and identified and more
than nine thousand people still missing
as reported by the Libyan red crescent
and the World Health Organization Dr
Ahmed zoitan of who World Health
Organization called the disaster of epic
proportions
of the red crescent noted that bodies
were washing up on the beaches as far as
150 kilometers away and FYI there's
flooding going on in a bunch of
different places that we can show as
well it's eight different big floods
going on around the world at the same
time so what's the reasoning behind it
is it one
it's God is upset and you know he is
upset with what we're doing with his
kids he's upset with what we're doing
what's been given to us is it mother
nature is it climate change or the fact
that it's all happening at the same time
a you know an agenda that's taking place
I asked this question on Monday morning
with my c-suite Executives just a spark
conversation what are your thoughts on
what's going on with this what's the
reason that's actually a story that I
actually follow pretty closely because
I'm born and raised in Miami we've been
dealing with flooding forever especially
in Miami Beach and South Beach
it floods we're on the bay we're near
the ocean the bay overflows especially
in the canals the streets get flooded
what we've done in Miami is we've risen
raised the streets like literally they
they bring the street up uh five feet so
if you look at the cities that are the
most vulnerable to flooding here's uh in
shurify because I trust insurance
companies because they actually have to
pay out it's kind of like how Vegas has
to pay out when there's odds Miami on a
score of 1 through 100 a hundred wow
number one city in America and there's
three states that are basically affected
by flooding
um in the United States there's Miami
Miami Florida there's Hialeah there
there's Hollywood Florida which is 10
minutes south of us where we did the
Vault and
um I believe Tampa's on this list then
you have New York Brooklyn uh
New Jersey City all basically outer
bureaus or New York City and then you
have certain cities in Texas so in the
United States the cities that should be
the most focused on this I assume are
right Miami's taking action I have no
clue what New York is doing I don't know
what Eric Adams is doing certainly don't
don't know what Bill de Blasio was doing
I know that Bloomberg was doing all
right and obviously your people down in
Texas are doing their thing but when it
comes to cities most vulnerable in the
world
um nobody is taking it higher than in
China India and
um I believe it's Indonesia but
southeast Asia so the the the the the
the hemispheres or the parts of the
world that should be the most attentive
to this are North America and Asia
specifically southeast Asia but if you
want to go Tom Ellsworth and get some
stats here
um the temperatures have risen by an
average of 0.14 Fahrenheit per decade
since 1880 why 1880 because that's
post-industrial Revolution right which
was late 1700s American Revolution to
basically almost the Civil War or
basically machines took over hand work
persons versus machines so this is what
concerns gen Z which I understand
especially if this is all they hear so
since the Industrial Revolution
temperatures have risen two percent
degrees Fahrenheit hotter okay that's
overall the rate of warming since 1980
however is two times as rapid 0.32 per
decade 2022 was the warmest year ever on
record we'll see where 2023 finishes
we're not done yet and bottom line is
the 10 warmest years
uh on historical record have all
occurred since 2010. so the question is
the question is not is the globe getting
warmer it certainly is if you believe
science and trusted science and all this
information if you want to fact check me
is that the NOAA the National
Association of atmosphere Administration
um dot gov but to what extent is human
activity in this right so we've seen it
since the post-industrial revolution
machines the fogs the cars
um airplanes we see that you have
Leonardo DiCaprio's of the world and the
people flying to Davos while they're
saying yeah global warming yeah so to
what extent is human activity but the
bottom line is it's expected to go five
degrees Fahrenheit higher by the end of
the century so is this something that I
think about every single day my demise
no I kind of want to work I kind of want
to live my life kind of do my thing but
when I'm driving in the streets of Miami
and it's flooded it's kind of hard not
to pay attention to what's going on
so Tom what do you think is going on
here
who's had cycles and these Cycles have
come and gone you know archaeologists
why do we always find old civilizations
under six feet of dirt because something
happened and it flooded and it covered
them up now is that to say that you know
all the pollution that we create is good
no less pollution in any form would be
better but are we dramatically driving a
hundred percent of what we see no I I I
don't think so I think the Earth's
headed Cycles we have a cycle that's
going on now we've had ice ages that
came and go and you know if the caveman
had CNN they would have been worried
about global cooling for several
centuries so are we having an impact
sure man is having something of an
impact but I think there's also cycles
that happen and you can look back in
history and kind of see the way
structures of Earth and geology have
changed from time to time there have
been Cycles Liz
I think I would probably take a little
more pragmatic approach to it so you
mentioned the temperature difference
between 1880 and now well 1880 is the
year that we started tracking global
temperatures so it's not that since 1880
we've seen all these changes that's that
we didn't track temperatures before that
so it's not really quite fair to
um quite fair to compare that I think
infrastructure and the increase in
infrastructure especially in the United
States plays into it I mean if you want
to use New York as an example their
sewer system for sewer water made of
clay pipes that haven't been replaced in
like 100 years obviously their
infrastructure is crumbling their
infrastructure is also like if you look
at the skyline of New York City now
compared to 100 years ago it's much
different right so as we continue to
build look at Miami for example you've
seen those before and after pictures of
Miami as we continue to build up
infrastructure in these cities that are
on the coast or are vulnerable to storms
that's obviously going to cause greater
damage because we've chosen to build
there
um I'm skeptical of the claims made by
the climate alarmists that say say that
that the Industrial Revolution and and
CO2 and fossil fuels are responsible for
this because I don't think that they
give I think I think that they lose some
credibility when they don't also State
what the positives for Humanity have
been for these things and they've had so
many of their predictions debunked even
since like the 1980s these climate
alarmists have told us that we're gonna
have States falling off that polar bears
are going to die that Greenland's going
to be covered in water and none of the
things that they've said I mean five
years ago Greta thundberg said we were
going to be dead by now and we're not
they're not really very credibly
science-based people so I suspect that
there's an agenda behind the alarmism
because that is what ruling class
typically does is they try to spark fear
in the hearts of people in order to push
an agenda we've it's pretty clear what
their agenda is whether it's coming from
AOC or from the world economic Forum
they really want to move us towards a
more socialist economy just based on
fear so let me let me ask you this
because you made some Fair points
especially you know word Greta Thunder
go to uh school yeah for this he did no
she's not she's 14. she's got laughs
every time she gets arrested she's
certainly used as a pawn by whoever is
pulling the strings no doubt and I do
agree that there's to an extent uh
climate alarmism and gen Z has fallen
major victim to this you can see that
they've yeah that's their number one
priority it's the number one my question
is you also made a valid point about the
Industrial Revolution 1880 but
how do you explain the last 10 years
have been the hottest ever so I get the
1880 but how do you explain the last 10
years well there are like he was saying
there are fluctuations in global
temperatures I mean over 10 years yeah
we go through warm periods we go through
cool periods we really don't we really
don't have enough scientific data to
make sweeping statements about what
these what these temperature Cycles mean
because we have such a limited amount of
data I'm no scientist I'm no scientist
it's a straight gut but you can I would
assume this happens over tens of
thousands of years there's like Ice Age
the heat age whatever the Mesozoic the
Paleolithic all this stuff happens over
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
years but 10 years that seems seems
pretty extreme to Me Maybe to go up that
much like I would like an explanation
for maybe 10 years because I mean if you
feel if you want to get biblical and
stuff it feels like the devil is
running the show right now maybe that's
maybe that's what it's because you think
about it Adam if you think about it
there are micro Cycles in addition to
the macro cycles that they're going to
be small fluctuations just saying 10
years is is quite the micro cycle over
ten thousand I just look at the data
from even the U.S intergovernmental
panel on climate change not exactly your
conservative think tank over there they
released a report I think it was from
2022 that said that debunked what a lot
of these climate alarmists were saying
about tornadoes and hurricanes and
floods and said no these these natural
disasters aren't occurring with greater
severity or more frequency that's just a
talking point we we suffer greater
damage because our infrastructure is
built up so much more and people stand
to lose so much more and maybe that's
something we need to address when we're
when we're building up in certain areas
of the country or certain areas of the
world but I'm just a little confused by
The Narrative that we hear from
politicians or this fear-mongering that
is causing gen Z to suffer like one in
five genzir suffers insomnia over fear
of climate disaster
I'm confused about why we are telling
gen Z that we are going to die based on
climate alarmism when even the most
leftist organizations like Noah the
National Oceanic and atmosphere
Association or the UN are saying
actually what these climate alarmists
are claiming about natural disasters
isn't true but Liz I doesn't this come
down to two things it's number one is
there alarmism and activism and fake
news going on about this issue yes
but is it an issue I also say yes so
it's not like it's right or wrong or
it's a binary choice where it's do
nothing nothing to see here don't do
anything versus stop everything you're
doing this is the number one issue we're
all gonna die there has to be some
Nuance here even Tom who's the
professional fact Checker said
there's Cycles but you also said
to some extent man-made to how much
extent do you think no I said I said If
You're Gonna argue with me about CO2
I'll say Okay anytime we pollute lakes
and air less that's good yeah right I'm
not but I'm not saying it's that it's
correlated and what's very very
interesting she brought up about Noah
Noah got caught with their pants down 11
years ago on modifying the data number
one Kofi Annan got caught with his pants
down saying well this is really about
economic redistribution that that the
climate change argument at the U.N level
is about economic redistribution from
the rich countries to the poor countries
so when I see those two things you know
science for me kind of takes a shot and
I say you know you know I you know what
I see in the weather I know what I see
around and we have Greater by the way it
is true that the natural disasters were
not happening with increasing frequency
but our awareness of the natural
disasters and instant news Cycles
Twitter have made us why wildly
available
Paul McCartney Paul McCartney went out
and did and you can go look this up Rob
did the concert for Bangladesh because
of these typhoons that would come in
annually and basically create incredible
suffering for these poor people just
masses of humanity third world country
with a lot of infrastructure and by the
way yet people like me that were going
to college going I didn't even know
about this why didn't we know about it
why didn't we know about Farm Aid
because in these time of media it was
brought more to our attention and so now
we go back and look at it and say you
know some of these natural disasters
have been happening just like that
natural disasters and they're more
prevalent in the front of your face now
than they were previously and so and
then you have no one people cut their
pants down that kind of that kind of
takes credibility away from me I'm like
oh so we're going to use climate change
this is bludgeon for economic
redistribution and speaking of
government and them having their their
way with it you guys have all heard of
weather modification right it's an act
of intentionally manipulating or
altering weather the most common is
called cloud seeding which increases
rain or snow usually for the purpose of
increasing the local water supply which
in my dude if you can control the
weather who knows what the hell they do
because Pat and then this says uh you
could damage use it for damaging weather
against the enemy as a tactic of
military or economic Warfare like
operation Popeye where clouds were
seated to prolong the monsoon uh in
Vietnam so I don't know bro if the
government can control weather and do
what they want and they want to push an
agenda of climate change and it starts
pouring raining in New York that I've
never seen that but I'm from New York
never ever since I've been I've I've
seen it that that bad and infrastructure
this this Administration ran on
infrastructure it's like how bad is it
lacking where the streets of New York
just on a on a downfall like that shut
down the whole city I have a question
for you Adam so one of the things that I
think is interesting and I like having
these conversations with good faith
people even when we don't necessarily
come out from the same perspective but
one of the ways that I differentiate
between science and ideology is whether
there's demonstrable proof that
substantiates a claim right versus just
presenting an unfalsifiable claim
because an unfalsifiable claim you could
argue that a lot of faith is based on
something that can't be proved you can't
necessarily scientifically prove that
God exists but the basis of science is
that you can prove something over and
over and over again so one of the things
that I often notice with people talking
about the human impact and will even put
the climate alarmists aside for a second
but people that talk about the human
impact uh on whether like CO2 and what
it's done to our climate what is how do
you how do you know like what is your
proof because you're making a pretty
what seems to me like an unfalsifiable
claim you're saying to me well our
temperatures have increased by a
fraction of a percent and over here we
also have flooding therefore I'm going
to assume that they are not only
correlated but directly correlated what
is the proof of that there is none you
bring up a valid point and uh here's
what you talk about arguing in good
faith like in any negotiation or any
conversation let's start with what we
agree upon right
do we want to live on Earth
yes do we love our planet yes am I
trying to move to Mars no despite my
invitation from Elon Musk do we want the
temperature to rise to a point where we
can't survive hell no so if if we have
some basis of agreement because I think
things get so politicized you love the
earth I hate the Earth you hate it's
like no that's not what it is I just
want to know what the what the proof is
because you'd think if it was if if
human behavior especially like fossil
fuels and CO2 were a direct cause of
even the increase in temperature that
led to an increase in severity and
frequency of storms then you would see
that data and yet the data shows that
there is not an increase in frequency
and severity so it seems to me that that
undercuts the claim and I'm just
wondering what what substantiates that
claim otherwise it's just ideology right
BBD is all about debates and discourse
conversation the the the conversation
you had a week ago with the Muslims and
the Christians was fantastic I know you
said you want to do more of those
what have you done or what are your
thoughts on having this type of debate I
know we've had climate people on but
have you had this debate she's asking
you a very good question by the way just
so you know and I think she's waiting
for an answer but but I will say this to
you uh what I'll say to you is you know
we've always Rob and I will invite
people to debate
people from the other side who say no
it's not as catastrophic as you make it
out to be the people that are fully
convinced climate change is real don't
want to do the debate don't know why the
same experience I had during covet the
people that said why don't we look at
other options for you know uh covid why
don't we question why there's certain
challenges with the vaccine the people
that said no you got to take the vaccine
no matter what never wanted to debate
the other people that were doing
research again I don't know why what
I've learned the same reason why I
brought up Newsom the other day I said
look I love that I respect the fact that
newsom's willing to go and sit down with
Hannity and you know you got some people
on the right that are not willing to go
sit down with anybody else on the left
or Obama never came and sat down with
anybody on the right I respect anybody
that's willing to do the debate you got
to respect that but on the climate
change side this this side doesn't like
to debate with the other side I don't
know why anyways let's move on to the
next topic I'd like to go through six
more topics and we only have an hour
left okay so next LeBron James wife and
two Associates named in federal ped
investigation story that just recently
came out and it's got a lot of people
saying is LeBron doing GH as young
growth hormone is this the Lance
Armstrong story that's about to come out
and they're going to strip him of all
these different accolades that he has so
let's read it LeBron James close
associate Earnest Mims business manager
and David Alexander trainer have been
named an unredacted Federal document
related to the biogenesis Scandal
however there is no accusation or
evidence of LeBron James using
performance enhancement drugs in the
reports the biogenesis Scandal
previously implicated major league
baseball players like Ryan Braun
and Nelson Cruz leading to suspensions
for 21 players
Ernest Mims was cited for buying
Controlled Substances for personal use
while David Alexander was listed as a
miami-based personal trainer for LeBron
James's wife LeBron James and other
athletes were not directly named in the
case and James's representative stated
that he had no prior knowledge of his
name being referenced in biogenesis
investigation now Rob can you pull up a
picture with LeBron James uh uh on let
me read that to you if you found out let
me just read that a representative for
James told ESPN that uh Los Angeles
Lakers had no knowledge he his wife or
his associate were even referencing a
biogenesis investigation until
approached by the media organization
last year ESPN's request to interview
James and Mims were declined after they
provided James's camp with applicable
information to back up their questioning
it's clear ESPN's reporting on the
subject took over a Year's worth of
research and while this is first needle
moving action
first needle moving action involving the
biogenesis case in several years it's
surely not going to be the last can you
find a picture just Google is LeBron
James taking ped with his body Tom I'm
going to go to you first because there's
a story of this that came out with
Peyton Manning we had his neck accident
what are your thoughts on the story here
with LeBron James and Peyton Manning
well look I mean
there's there's smoking guns here but
there is a huge economic interest to the
NBA not to have not to have
um your number one star have an issue
like this they saw what happened with
A-Rod Manny Ramirez and how baseball
baseball took such black eyes so there's
a lot of economic interest in the NBA
not to have this happen but the other
side of it there appears to be a
Playbook here because when Peyton
Manning hurt his neck supposedly he was
receiving certain
substances that you came to his wife and
I don't recall seeing Ashley kind of
beef up or be bench pressing Honda
Civics
um and he had a need a very big medical
need because they were trying to heal
the fuse of the vertebrae on his neck
and he was having trouble doing that and
there was this there was certain muscle
deterioration that happened that as a
result of the surgery and people said
well if an average individual was using
these things I would be actually
prescribing them unfortunately he's an
individual who is uh he makes a living
where they have a book that says you
can't use these things so I I think
Deadspin have it right you know they
call them Wags yeah wives and
girlfriends yeah they've changed it this
morning they're now Pags and it's some
pharmacist of the girlfriends so it's um
it's it's a completely different
category now or your wife is actually
you know not just supporting your career
she's supporting your career okay so let
me ask you a question you think actually
something's going to come out that
LeBron's doing ped and he's to get
caught and the story is going to get
public you think they're going to take
it to that level like they did with
Lance Armstrong because you know they
they fully ganged up on Lance to destroy
his legacy right and that's more of an
individual sport sport it's slightly
different and one would say how much
money and sponsorship is in cycling
although he probably brought a lot of
attention to cycling being the greatest
cyclist of all time everybody was
talking about it and this this is a
behemoth of a league franchise he's a
face this would be a black guy for the
NBA for his legacy for being the
greatest for being all that I have a
complete different argument for this uh
on on what I think when I think about
you know by the way did you find a
picture of the guy if you find a a
picture with LeBron
I'll answer your question yes I think
this is a Smoking Gun but I think
there's so much at stake for the NBA
that they got to put the smoke out well
zoom in on that zoom in on that picture
right there that's what Marcellus Wiley
okay
look I mean that's let's just start with
the basics LeBron is an absolute
specimen of a human being he is an
absolute Beast even in high school yeah
the guy was massive so
if
if there's somebody that may not need to
take steroids it might be
arguably the greatest physical athlete
of all time now do I do we know if he's
actually doing or doing that we know
that he takes very good care of his body
ironically you know he played for the
heat David Alexander who is the trainer
here
I've known him for years he married a
girl I went to high school with Natasha
so I know these people they're around
they're like they're not random people
in random
basements selling drugs he's a very
famous Miami fitness trainer he's not
some low-key weird dude so is Randy Mims
I don't know why they called him Ernest
mips but he goes by Randy I've seen him
a million times in Miami that's his
business manager now if he is doing
something it'd be pretty damn sloppy to
put it in your wife's name you've got
literally so many people in your inner
circle you're going to do this with but
David Alexander has trained LeBron he's
trained Dwyane Wade he's trained Chris
Paul he's a g I'm not saying that
there's no there there I'm just saying
this isn't the first time we've heard
this conversation about LeBron but at
the end of the day steroids are no
steroids he's still better than you and
he's still better than anybody in the
end he's getting but he's getting older
but he's getting older and to stay on
the top at him if there's if there's
little cheating that you don't see the
stuff like Tom was talking about like we
don't know but I mean to stay on top of
your game and going up about what you
said like the amount of money sponsors
and China I have to involved different
things can I say one thing yeah I'll
turn it over to you in basketball okay I
played basketball being big and strong
and bulky is not great for athleticism
you want to kind of be long and lean and
in shape and have a little bit of muscle
yeah but that's not when it comes to
neither was Lance Armstrong you're not
doing it to be a bodybuilder it's all
because of speedy recovery okay it's
what it's for and Lance Armstrong have
you ever seen can you put Lance
Armstrong's body when he was cycling
they got nothing to do with it's about
the fact that he's 39 years old playing
at the level that he's playing how many
games in the season pass he plays about
where I was going with it because when I
think of steroids I think of everything
that we've discussed in the bodybuilding
yeah that's not steroids okay so
literally I've never known for example
like you know how Joe Rogan says Hey
Rock why don't you just come out and say
you're under steroids right you're
taking stuff yeah it's like a little bit
like what are you doing yeah it's
obvious the people that have taken
they're like no you're on something it's
very obvious it's cool it's okay here's
my position with it okay you know how
back in the days it was kind of like
such and such smoke sweet oh my God
and now it's like what such and such
smokes weak okay what do you want me to
do bro like you have a life he smokes
sweet okay they need to get over this
fact that these guys are doing like they
need to legalize it already in sports
stop it like it absolutely stop it what
do you mean Legalize It you're saying
that yes they need to legalize you know
guys that are playing sports that are
you know putting their bodies through
being hit running non-stop yes they need
to take certain things that others are
not going to take like a formula race
car driver that's going 220 miles an
hour what do you think they're on to be
able to handle that two and a half hours
of whatever they're doing their body's a
different body they're drinking Vault
for sure Adderall no they take Adderall
okay so for me yeah do I think LeBron's
on things yes why everybody that's ever
been close to LeBron has said how shitty
of a diet he has he eats cookies he eats
everything you know when people eat
everything shitty and they still look
good there's a reason for it you can't
get away with eating shitty things ah
yeah you could get away with it in the
early 20s you can't get away with it in
your 30s 35 38 39 body changes a little
bit then oh hey LeBron let me tell you
he's always eating cookies he's always
eating ice cream he's always eating this
and you'll look like that you know fine
there's a part that you say genetics
there the other part of this maybe
sometimes you're taking with your body
all I'm saying is I don't have a problem
with athletes taking it I don't have a
problem with it they're athletes they're
playing a different game they're taking
a different risk race car drivers put
different kind of fuel in their cars you
don't put that in your car I drive a 93
octane whatever I put in my car you put
an 89 or an 87 oh my god did you know
Formula One what kind of octane do they
use in in F1 or NASCAR they're exotic
they're like 115. oh my God they're
cheating they have to put 115 octane in
those cars they're perf they're they're
risking their lives driving you're
worried about this guy putting steroids
on his body you should be worried about
other things most of these guys after
they're done playing you see how they
walk when they're 60 years old you know
they walk in a certain way with their
legs and their knees trust me they're
going to be having a lot of issues later
on so I don't have a problem
it being across the board that you're
doing it just like they're trying to
make you know weed legal in certain
things I I don't see it being an issue
but if it does come out today and you're
using it while it's illegal guess what
you broke the rules you broke the law
but later on if they need to kind of
transition into making a legal forever
have a league that's just all like
steroids whatever but it already is
anyways it's not like you have a league
by the way what percent of NBA players
do you think right now are taking
illegal it's like 80 percent smoke weed
yeah 80 smoke weed are you saying wheat
are you saying PD like things that
anything any substance that they're not
supposed to do well weeds would you
consider weed being one of them or no
marijuana is definitely up there they're
definitely smoking weed I don't think
you're putting weed no not for
professional okay so you're purely
talking performance enhancement drugs
what percentage of NBA players I would
say 20 I was gonna say 35 maybe 30 35
would that that sold Over the Rainbow
NFL NFL
what 70 80 but by the way guess what you
do you see what they're doing like how
fast oh yeah what do you what do you you
know how easy the average person they
they tackle you helmet to helmet you're
dead yeah
isn't that an argument against maybe not
doing steroids in the NFL I mean these
guys are yeah but they do to their
bodies
but he made a great Point Listen to
Playing an NFL game and the recovery in
one week think about it in one week
after you're having these Giants hit you
I think it should be a no-brainer they
need the stuff to recover we've seen the
case study on this you saw a little case
study on this and it's called Major
League Baseball Pat and I followed it
majorly baseball had an era where
they're they're testing equipment was so
bad and they're testing frequency was so
bad and your ability to travel every six
days from place to place and to avoid
testing was so good that you had
literally baseball was powered by
steroids we all knew it was it was Zero
Sammy So son Mark McGuire and Kevin
Brown the pitcher and there were
pitchers using it why did pitchers use
it they used it for one reason recovery
Lance Armstrong he was focused on IPO
EPO and
recovery EPO oxygen treatment every
other cyclist was used
big enough that you know they even with
the same thing that he was using they
couldn't beat him yeah but he lost his
legacy with the whole thing every time
people see him right now they no longer
say you're the steroid guy correct
remember to Live Strong the yellow
wristband what happened to the point
that if it's so prevalent make it legal
I don't know whether I agree with that
or not you guys probably have more
opinions on sports that I do but I don't
think that the viewership of these
professional leagues would accept it as
easily obviously as the players and
trainers because one of the fun parts of
watching sports is watching human beings
who are so much better than we are
playing this athletic competition and it
just feels like cheating it feels like
oh are you actually doing that or are
you only doing that because you have
access to certain types of drugs that
make you do it you bring up a great
point I don't know if people I don't
know if people would accept that because
think about how disappointed and
devastated it wasn't just a media hit
job against Lance Armstrong people were
kind of disappointed it because when you
are a fan of sports these players are
your Idols you're like if only you could
live up to this kids want to be them and
then it's like well are you even real it
becomes like you bring up a great point
because it's all Optics like for
instance I was like oh it makes you
bigger and stronger and you're a muscle
head steroids it's like no it's actually
somewhat used for Recovery all right I
generally didn't know that because I'm
not actively playing any major sports so
if they fit because the con if I don't
know that think about the common fan
they're just like he's on steroids oh my
God it's like no it's actually I
sprained my ankle and I want to recover
sooner so there's there's a there's a
part to what you're saying that is so
valid because what is the what is the
fan gonna think how is this gonna taint
it use the baseball analogy we all
remember what happened with Sammy Sosa
Mark McGuire I think it's an absolute
shame that arguably the greatest bass
player of all time not named Babe Ruth
Barry Bonds is not in the Hall of Fame
because he used steroids but everyone in
the league was using steroids at that
time we all know that the he I think it
was under the Bush Administration they
were having Court hearings
week long month long year-long
investigations into steroids during the
war in Iraq and Afghanistan it's like
get your priorities straight Rafael
primeros went in there any
yeah would you guys be disappointed if
you found out that Michael Jordan had a
bionic leg
would that disappoint you because the
other thing that's going to disappoint
me about Michael Jordan did you see Eric
like it's something that it's not it's
like it's metal graphite that it wasn't
he's not 100 human basically yeah would
you be disappointed if you found out
that like oh okay
he wasn't fully like there's a couple
things different things here you you
feel like that's how people would view
it no I I don't know about that because
to me uh how many people in the world
have a six-pack
how many people in America have a six
packs
for sure Google what percentage of
Americans have a six-pack can you do
that and Pat I'm actually really caring
you'll see what point I'm making here
right now what percentage of Americans
have a six-pack I'm going with two
percent no way what if they have this
let's go ape they should have it so
there it is what is it number Americans
with six packs 25 000. okay I don't know
if it's that high but go see if go see
if there's another study on that uh uh
what percentage is it easier to be a
millionaire or six but there's an
article that says it's easier to be a
millionaire than to have a six-pack okay
but here's the point okay can anybody
have a six-pack yes yeah of course can
anybody have a six-pack so we don't look
at these athletes and say they're doing
things that we can't do no no they're
doing things that we don't want to do
okay so that's one thing we respect them
for because they're more disciplined to
take care of their health I respect the
fact that LeBron uh is playing at 38 39
years old with his body there's a lot of
guys that let their bodies go Carmelo
Anthony could have taken care of his
body they came at the same time but
Carmelo Anthony wasn't as disciplined
with his body you know there was Antoine
Walker who was at one point an All-Star
doing great things I sat down and talked
to the guy when we sat down and talked
to him I'm like Antoine how did you
become 400 pounds he was 400 pounds when
I sat him at a cigar lounge in Chicago
because it's hard to take care of your
health so there's an element that we
automatically think that these guys have
god-given abilities and that's the only
reason why they do what they do it
requires a lot more than just that yes
some people have it but for example you
know Michael Jordan versus Vince Carter
Vince Carter's a better dunker than
Michael Jordan how come Michael Jordan
ended up becoming a you know who he
became in Vince Carter this is not easy
it's way more than just the physical
side it's the mental side it's the
discipline to go to the gym that is why
we respect them I don't think we respect
them to say well that guy's taking stuff
and I'm not uh I think that's a
different element but for me the average
person also
the same way the average person doesn't
understand what an entrepreneur goes
through when they start a company and
then they want to demonize the founder
that started a company or the
capitalists are like yeah look at him
he's got all this money he goes to the
nice restaurants lives in the house and
yeah but did you work 100 hours a week
for 20 years once you go do it because
you can do it too you can work 100 hours
a week you can go out there and read
books instead of watching every damn
Netflix show the last time I watched the
only series I've ever watched on my TV
on Netflix is House of Cards and I've
watched lasso because Greg sure told me
lhasa reminds him of you so I had to
watch Ted lasso a couple episodes to see
it but yes I think it's very uh
I think the audience not going to change
I think for me it's purely recovery and
we have to understand that these guys as
lives is a different lives than the ones
we're living not saying they don't have
a great life they have a great life but
it's very hard to do with them and you
made a great point about Lance and how
all these other guys were taking the
same type of uh procedure that Lance was
but you know people quickly forgot that
his Live Strong that bracelet cancer
thing he raised over 500 million dollars
for cancer research treatment and
support put 6.5 million of his own money
and it's just funny how he gets caught
and they vilify him and they're like to
help with him he saved millions of what
he does today he's a podcaster he's a
podcast
strong after the allegations yeah but
nobody cares about the 500 million over
500 why don't we talk about something
important like sending a bird cage to a
friend as a gift let's talk about
something like that so Nikki Haley says
Trump campaign sent her bird cage after
he called her birth brain
so you know let's see what let's see
what Liz has got to say about this one
you're living I'm really curious to hear
your take on this one okay so a former
comedian and president Donald Trump
that's not the headline but Nikki Haley
draws insults from Trump and uh and sign
she is gaining ground in Republican
presidential race former president Trump
launched the entire thing calling about
you know bird brain and declaring Maga
or I will never go bird brain Nikki
Haley Nikki Haley gained recognition for
impressive performance and a recent
Republican debate earning praise for her
rhetorical prowess a post-debate poll
conducted by
538 shows that 62 percent of respondents
rated her performance positively
signaling a notable boost in her
standing with GOP race so one what do
you think about the gift president Trump
sent her and then two do you really you
think that she's becoming more and more
formidable it's just a season here what
are your thoughts well I don't doubt she
she put a picture up on social media of
the of the bird cage in the bird seed I
don't doubt that she yeah there it is I
don't doubt she received that at her
door
I'm a little skeptical that it came from
the Trump campaign I think someone who
did it just for a gag and signed the
Trump campaign because they knew that it
would get the attention that it gets I'm
not sure that that's funny enough that
the Trump campaign would actually do it
he's never done anything like that and
Nikki he's not worried about Nikki Haley
he's not worried but but you know what I
hold on I wish I was there if it is true
if he was like you know what send it and
hey bird food too but but you know what
I saw that pen I thought if it is true
hands down what a gamer he doesn't give
a damn if you're male female young old
cute ugly if it's a competition if
that's true he doesn't give two shits
he's going after your ass and if that is
him that is one of the funniest things
Pat because I know he's trying to like
that's like go trying to go after like
her brain that guy's hilarious bro he's
a comedian I mean it's funny I just I
don't know I am very skeptical that it
came from the Trump campaign I think it
came from she makes a great Point by the
way you never know can you confirm this
because I don't see any word that
Trump's Camp confirmed sending no The
Birdcage you heard what he said after
Chris Christie you saw that Chris
Christie Donald Duck like cringiest
insult and Trump's response to that was
hilarious he said anybody who comes up
with an insult like that isn't fit to be
president hahaha
well you know beyond all the merriment
here beyond all the merriment and
there's a couple of charts you have here
um it's very very interesting stuff so
National polls and National headlines
right now they don't matter here's what
matter what are the people of Iowa and
New Hampshire really thinking and are
those polls moving because that's where
the spring points are going to be right
now the national polls yeah oh my God
they illustrate a little bit but the
national polls are
not what's there take me to New
Hampshire that's Iowa let's go to New
Hampshire
take a look at that little red line in
the lower right corner she's coming to
santis is green uh he's not afraid of
Nikki Haley who's in red right there is
that right Haley so binoculars so
basically I look at this like this God
um what if all this legal stuff does
take Donald Trump out of the campaign I
don't think it will but if it does there
is a second game that's being played
down there you see what that is and that
is called when the New Hampshire primary
and you're going to win more support now
let's go to Iowa look at Nikki Haley boy
what a shot there now in Iowa look who's
number three Nikki Haley now 8.8 clearly
above Rama swanny now so what is
happening is in the polls that matter is
who where we're going to be voting in
these and it's not a fair game Iowa and
New Hampshire are going to be
springboards of contributions and
support and everything but I look at it
and Nikki Haley is running a really good
campaign and she is now honestly number
two in these states and gaining momentum
bit by bit including these headlines
that may or may not be sure about it I
still I still think he did it Tom you
know why I think he did it because
there's a clip of him speaking a couple
days ago Pat where I think Rob has it I
don't know if you saw this Liz where
he's talking about how they're trying to
be environmentally safe and he said
while he was uh a president somebody
came to him from the dod and they were
like sir we have a new fighter jet that
we want it's environmentally friendly
and he goes who gives the damn if it's
defined we're dropping bombs and
shooting people who gives the damn Rob
do you have that so that fight's
supposed to screams listen to that I
think there's music though is there
music
but it is hilarious if you haven't seen
that clip that's why he's a comedian
wrong yeah he's 100 told you so I was
like with that type of humor I wouldn't
see him I wouldn't put a passing Pat
that he sent this here's what I'm saying
I want to know who actually said that
we're making jets that are
environmentally friendly well they want
to make they want they suggestion making
one that is environmental but part of
war is environmentally friends
you know the department of the dod is
probably for sure going listen some
won't guy like let's make a jet that you
know is and he's like are you we're
dropping by comes on these people who
gives a about the environment you
know we're gonna kill your brother but
you know what we got him a life
insurance policy
I wouldn't put this past the dod though
blowing people up is a form of recycling
back to Nikki Haley we were at the RNC
debates uh I don't know four days ago a
week ago whenever that was uh in Simi
Valley California I've actually
performed very well I thought she was
the winner of the debate I thought I had
her first
DeSantis was kind of up there you saw
that in a national poll I know that
we're not crediting National polls that
she's actually the one person in the
race who would significantly beat Biden
not Trump not DeSantis Nikki Haley so
what we do know is he actually did call
her bird brain that's not like me yeah
he did he tweeted it and you know if we
trust modern journalism today journalist
Mark Caputo confirmed The Birdcage was
sent by the Trump campaign but to me
that's irrelevant whether he sent it or
didn't sent it to me is the fact that he
said it we all know that his jokes and
his his slurs
you have the clip with no music hold on
the deeper thing here and I have mixed
feelings on Trump and I love him slowly
coming around to at least understanding
where he's at because I do think there
is a
two things can be true at once I do
think the media the Deep State The
Matrix there is an agenda to bring this
man down I don't think that's deniable
at this point yeah and at first it was
Russia Russia Russia well it turns out
yeah it's actually some fake news going
on yeah some but at the same time he
could also be sort of a reckless
wrecking ball narcissistic as many
people call him man-child two things can
be true at once yeah okay just because
you're this way doesn't mean that the
media or the Deep State Should attack
you so I understand why he has Vengeance
and he's vindictive and he's essentially
seeking retribution for whatever
wrongdoing he sees but more importantly
the wrongdoing that he's
um fighting for in the Republican base
totally understand that my question is
this so you I don't know if you saw what
his former Chief of Staff his longest
standing Chief of Staff General Joan
Kelly came out with this weekend a
scathing rebuke
my question is this
Nikki Haley bird brain he selected her
to be the ambassador of the the UN why
would you select a bird brain to
represent your country you selected Mike
Pence to be your vice president why
would you select someone that is
disloyal and doesn't have your back to
be your BP he selected Bill Burr he
selected Mike Pompeo he selected Chris
Christie to be the person that would
train him he selected scaramucci to be
my only question this isn't a statement
my only question is why are all the
closest people that he's selected now
his biggest detractors and that's
something that he needs to address my
opinion well I mean he can't go ahead I
actually agree with that I think that
Trump was a very good president for
three years I don't think he handled
covet very well in his fourth year but I
think one of his shortcomings was
um how he always ended contentiously
with various staff members I don't think
that that's a very positive commentary
on him I will say I thought Nikki Haley
was a fantastic ambassador to the UN she
did a really really good
um I don't think that the Republican
electorate is going to like her
regardless of whether Trump is running
or not because the vast majority of the
Republican electorate right now is
against the war in Ukraine and against
sending more U.S money to Ukraine and
Nikki Haley never met a war she didn't
like she's kind of she's kind of this
generation's neocon and I don't think
that that's a good match and she's very
outspoken about it too so I think that
there's a pretty big mismatch I think
she'd have a hard time even if Trump
were out of the picture which I don't
think he will be but I think she'd have
a hard time winning support from
Republicans who especially the
Republicans who understand that sending
so much
so many US dollars to Ukraine is
devaluing our dollar which is increasing
inflation which is going to cause the
rest of the world to you know discard
the US dollar which is going to lose us
our economic power in the world which is
really our biggest strength I mean
there's an existential threat to our
country that's happening in Ukraine and
it's not just the actual battles that
are being fought there it's the policy
and she's in support of it yeah well Liz
I don't disagree with the Quant that you
just made there that's a that's a very
good Quant but when you look at it the
voters are going to go with the choices
they have and it's all the choices that
are on the ballot and she's on the
ballot versus these other choices and
that's that's that's the plate plate of
fruit to pick from and so you you look
at it right now she's shining and she's
showing you know demonstrable and by the
way I'm not I'm not voting yet so I'm
not lobbying here I'm saying objectively
polls are showing in key States and on
National reaction polls that Adam was
talking about that she is reflecting
well against the other Alternatives and
I think what you
or what may be behind your point which I
would support is that the truth of what
America really feels on a broad scale
there's not really the choice that they
would overwhelmingly go for based on
their absolute proven and defined views
can I ask no that's not can I ask Vinnie
a question a question yeah you can tell
great stories
purely out of genuine curiosity I love
the exchange you had with Steve Schmidt
last week shout out to you that clip
went viral you did your thing you know
part of
um
what gave you Credence and credibility
it was like look I served in the
freaking military yeah I was there I
wore the uniform I was in the Air Force
yeah you know then there's this whole
conversation about Trump versus the
generals right whether it's General
Millie General Kelly
um who was his first uh General that
Matt zappala interviewed at Mattis yeah
Mad Dog Mattis a lot of these guys are
finding issue with Trump so I'm just
going to read the words and I want to
get your thoughts this is Kelly General
Kelly he's Chief of Staff basically
saying my issue with him was that he
thought that all wounded soldiers were
suckers he did not want to be seen in
any sort of parade with them he didn't
want them around and this is a guy this
is a general saying this is hearsay this
is well this is I mean is it proof that
is I I because again Adam I always want
proof I always want proof he said it
wait wait I want to see or hear I mean
where he actually said that's where I'm
going to go to okay okay because I know
where you're going we know what he said
about McCain being captured if you want
the proof we could roll the table no I I
heard that
he's not working yeah he's not by the
way he's not Jesus Christ Adam that
guy's not Jesus Christ what's your
question Adam what's the question
I'm just asking as a former military
member yeah if these are true does this
not give you some sort of pause if if it
is true meaning true of course it would
it would it would bother someone mind
you he what he said about Mccain not the
coolest thing when when when blows come
to blow bro this guy like I said gamer
and doesn't like anybody betraying or
anybody talking and going back to
your initial point when you talked about
uh who was it Pompeo all the who was all
his bill bill Barr all these people what
are the choice did Trump have he's
coming in he wanted to run independent
couldn't had to become Republican not
once you're in you want you didn't even
really think that you were going to win
now you're in does he really have a
choice Liz on who he picks as all these
people meaning he doesn't they they were
telling him Mike Pence is probably going
to be your best choice this person the
generals you don't know they're they're
already appointed all these other people
in this circle at him he had to have
them and then guess what gradually
throughout time you know people's True
Colors show Nikki Haley maybe yeah he
liked her at the beginning but then she
turns on him and is that
guys we got 27 minutes I got my X7 call
I don't I can't go over today today's
Tuesday so a couple things I will say
one I I don't I don't know if I would
say bird brain after this podcast after
this debate why complete different
reason
when you're choosing VP you need the
other people to think that
she could be a possible candidate to be
a VP as a president you have to be
unpredictable when it comes down to your
VP why are you already undermining her
it automatically tells everybody that's
not the VP why are you doing that
strategically doesn't make any sense
there's no reason to say something like
this with bird brain just leave it alone
okay to make a comment like that I think
for me it's more coming from the
strategy standpoint you're giving too
much up by every time somebody's doing
good on the GOP debate you know what he
is saying to everybody what he's saying
to everybody is the fact that his VP is
not on that stage that's what he's
saying so the VP is now so is it going
to be Christy is that who you're going
to go after or maybe you're not going to
take Pence because it's like you lost
Indiana anyway so what was the purpose
of getting pens maybe you got the
Christian voter but you lost Indiana so
you figure Christy's like oh you're
trying to win Dakota well no it doesn't
matter anyway so he's giving too much of
his hand which is not of him when it
comes down to this that's the only thing
I would say second thing is you said
something very offensive on who he fired
you said he fired Bill Burr he never
fired Bill Bill I want to make sure we
clarify that's very offensive when you
go after a comedian like this I love the
guy it was Bill Barr you're right
English language
be fired under trump it just wouldn't
happen I could see Bill Burr and the
comedian Don Rickles AKA Donald Trump
going on tour together so anyways let's
go to the next one Liz you went after
Tristan Tate uh August 8th a month ago
two months ago we said the following
Liz wheeler claims Tristan Tate teaching
young men how to deceive women and take
their virginity a conservative political
commentator this girl named Liz will
right Liz I think you would like this
lady and podcast hosts recently
criticized Tristan Tate brother of
Andrew Tate allegedly promoting
deceptive tactics towards women wheeler
shared a video where Tate discussed
dating and said Tristan Tay teaches
young men how to lie to innocent woman
to take their virginity I'll do two or
three virgins per year I'll Teach You
How Jordan Peterson even responded and
supported you saying for advocating
family values and discipline join the
criticism by sharing Wheeler's tweet and
warning about the potential consequences
of weak men influenced by Tate's advice
Peterson wrote If you think strong men
are dangerous wait until you see what
weak men are capable of sincerely
someone a while ago if you want to play
the clip I don't know if you have the
video or not or is it just a tweet no I
put the video on the Tweet okay so go
back to that tweet and see if it Go Go
click on there you go yeah listen to
this
all right let's watch this and then
let's get your take and then we'll give
our feedback here
like me and meet the women who I meet
and roll in the circles I meet you meet
beautiful virgins sometimes
me I'll do two or three virgins a year
now how do you date a virgin when you're
a when you're an ice cold player there
is a tactic which I'm going to share
with you on how to date a virgin and how
to take a girl's virginity
Now the recipe hasn't changed but the
tactics and the implementation has
certainly changed be their boyfriend for
three months and be in a nice
relationship with them that is the
recipe I'm sorry guys you want to run
into a virgin and her the next day
don't ask me how I don't know I don't
think anyone knows I don't even think
it's possible
you have to be their boyfriend for an
extended period of time you then have to
take a virginity on the second month
anniversary or something along those
lines and I'm going to teach you how to
do it while still being you can find a
player you can pause it here so you got
it's a two minute video commentary
thoughts on this why you have a problem
with this well I mean the words that he
used make it pretty clear he said I'm
going to teach you a strategy I'm going
to teach you a tactic how to manipulate
a girl into sleeping with her to deceive
her into thinking that she is loved by
me in order to exploit her objectify her
and have sex with her that's pretty
disgusting I think by anybody's
standards
Adam I think one more comment I will
make the reason that I criticize him
specifically or that I've criticized
Andrew Tate is because at one point
Andrew Tate was the most Googled man in
the world he's incredibly influential
among young men and the reason it's very
interesting why he's influential because
he accurately diagnoses a serious
cultural problem in the west he
accurately notes that masculinity is
under assault that men are told that
they're toxic and bad and he actually to
his credit has the courage to say I'm
gonna push back against this I'm going
to tell men to be men the problem is
that once he accurately diagnoses the
problem his antidote what he prescribed
is self-destructive he doesn't actually
teach young men how to be good strong
men he instead leads them towards
pornography and materialism and
exploitation of Women In Worship of self
so I think that makes him more dangerous
because he does accurately diagnose a
problem but then his prescription for it
is to lead young men astray so
is your biggest issue with Andrew
interest in that Virgin video or sort of
sort of a symptom of a larger problem
that you that you have with them overall
I mean that video is an example of the
point that I make when people say that
Andrew and Tristan Tate are good role
models for young men I don't think
that's a good role model for young men
to learn how to manipulate and lie and
deceive women into having sex I actually
want to address that but I just actually
want to send your perspective genuinely
do you think that the Tate Brothers for
men specifically are a positive net
value positive net role model or
negative negative I think they lead
young men towards self-destruction okay
so you think that the words that they're
saying not the little Clips but their
overall message is bad for men not good
yes because what are they telling men
they're telling men you're attacked
you're a victim and that resonates with
men because that is a valid grievance
especially in especially in American
culture that's why they've become so
popular here they were popular in Europe
and in Britain but they're so popular
here the last couple of years because
there is a war on masculinity so young
men are feminized and it's a powerful
thing when you take a valid grievance
and then tell someone that the solution
to that grievance is something that
actually harms them so I actually think
they're more self-destructive than some
people on the left because they're
playing on a valid problem and
prescribing something that's harmful
just to be clear what do you think that
their prescription is for men
pornography materialism exploitation of
women and worship of self that's what
you think their message is to men that
is what they you can read all of their
stuff listed all their stuff I've I've
extensively listened to all of their
advice for young men and they literally
say if you are not extremely wealthy you
are not a real men money is the most
valuable thing like money's great we're
all trying to make a living here we're
all trying to make money but it is not
the most valuable thing that is a that
is a message of materialism they've run
pornography business that's how they got
rich that's how they got famous they
pretend to back away from it now just to
avoid criticism but it's really just
because they don't need to do that
anymore they they constantly or talk
about how to be a top G and how to
manipulate women I think that's an
incredibly destructive message do you
think that's positive for young men uh a
lot of it I do and I'll tell you why
that video do you think that video is no
I'll address that video but what it was
interesting is he actually had a nuanced
approach that you need to date them to
three months how many women are going to
date a guy for three months that they
are not interested in that is not there
for them that is not providing for them
that is not protecting from them that
isn't there for them you don't just slip
in and fall into a virgin I totally
understand that is you actually need to
date these women so at that point
the it's the woman's decision so my
question to you is how many men that's
deceptive like he's deceiving them he
doesn't actually care about them he's
doing things to make them think that he
cares about them you know what welcome
to modern day dating baby like this is
what happens out there men do this with
women women do this with men and you
don't think that's destructive
I think it is what it is whether it's
destructive or not is your opinion do
you think it is I'm interested in your
opinion do you think that that's a
harmful dating Dynamic I don't think
that that is my objective to dating
going out there and taking virginities
that's not my thing but going out and
dating multiple women I've done that
forever but do you think it's an honest
I don't want to focus on The Virginity I
want to focus on the bigger no you're
missing the point Liz what percentage of
men are millionaires in the world
I don't think that's the point the point
is what I'm asking you a question miss
Liz wheeler because I respect your
opinion you're beautiful you're smart
you're educated what percentage of men
are millionaires I don't know take a
guess you're smart I have no idea I'll
Google it fine okay tell me the answer
if you want the answer
eight percent of men let's say what
percentage of men are six foot with six
packs we just did this earlier
I mean I'm not six foot but what
percentage
all right well I don't even know what
while you're Googling this Millions
millionaires six foot
ABS in shape
actually a man who is good looking fit
takes care of this person a man who can
provide protect be present for his woman
these to become the top G Liz what does
he mean what does that mean to you a
top gangster oh what does that
mean a top like a Top Male a high value
alpha male okay that's what you're
saying what do you love about your
husband go ahead I love that he is Godly
I love that he is a man of virtue I love
that he is strong I love that he is a
man of integrity I love that how tall is
your husband 510 he's five ten he
probably serves in the U.S Navy so he's
border patrol
provider I met your husband
so let me get this straight he's a tall
good-looking studly man who's done well
for himself
yes okay don't you think it's incumbent
on most men to try to accomplish that to
be materially successful I didn't say
that to be good-looking successful
leader in shape lead men don't you think
that's important for men I think the
number one most important thing for men
to do is to try to be Godly that's your
opinion it is yes okay that's your
opinion I'm answering your question
though you're asking my opinion if I
think those things are important I think
the most important thing for a man to do
is to be Godly I think to provide and
pursue why did you marry your children
priests don't get married okay well
that's their bet but there are some
pastors that do get married when you
marry a pastor if that's the most family
unit the marriage
to get pressure off the Altar Boys
I feel like you're trying to see where
you're going with this okay
the point is this you're you're
lambasting this man
for accomplishing what very few men can
accomplish the fact that he's made all
this repeat to me what I said when you
say I lambastian for what he's
accomplished I don't care how much money
he has what did I say my problem why are
you focused on the money what did I say
my problem was you're missing the entire
point of my point tell me what your
point is why do so many men
so many men not just impressionable 13
year olds men grown ass
men yeah 40 years old successful
good values moral compass strong leaders
why do those men
find him fascinating and resonate with
him answer me that yes I do grown as men
not teenagers actually love these guys
let me tell you why yes and it's what I
said before because they're all toxic
masculinity do you I mean you live in
the United States of America you
understand that the most powerful
politicians and the most powerful
cultural influences James Cameron for
goodness sake in Hollywood called
testosterone a toxin men are told that
if they so much as pursue a woman or ask
her on a date that they are sexually
harassing men right now aren't afforded
due process of law when they face
frivolous allegations of sexual
misconduct that could be to the level of
criminal conduct do you understand how
vulnerable this makes young men yeah
because I'm a man I understand what it
is I know that's what I think
why men resonate with him because of how
powerfully men react to being attacked
and then you have Andrew Tate and
Tristan Tate coming in and saying I see
you and that attack that's happening
against You Is Wrong you've done don't
have to face that I'm going to give you
the secret to avoiding that into
succeeding anyway when everything from
the education system to our legal system
to our culture is telling men that they
are worthless that they are bad that
they're inherently rapists I mean it's
bad what's happening to men they come in
and say I have a solution so that you
don't have to live that that's more
powerful than a drug Adam that's why men
finally attractive you bring up a good
point but you've never been a man
so you're arguing with me a grown-ass
man and amongst other men what it's like
to be a man and what we're feeling I can
assure you this my lovely friend the
number one thing that men are not taking
from Andrew Tata is the the matriarchy
is coming against you and you can't go
out and talk to women it's actually the
exact opposite it's oh you want warm
women in your life you want more success
in your life you want better cars bigger
things bigger dreams more beautiful
women in your life follow these steps
not you're a victim I understand you
I'll give you a hug let me show you how
it's okay what's going on I've used one
of Andrew Tate's words that he uses to
describe the attack on masculinity about
an hour ago on this show That's How
Deeply Andrew Tate's message is in your
own mind I'm observing it what's the
word The Matrix okay he's the one that
made that word AF long after the movie
become a staple in every young man's
vocabulary The Matrix is after you
here's how you avoid the Matrix here's
how you're successful in spite of the
Matrix I'm not telling you how to feel
you don't feel how everyone what's your
point what's your react because I said
the word let's ask a different question
here let me because I'm still trying to
figure out where okay so Tom question
for you that video right there with how
to take three rivers virginities per
year what do you think about as a father
of two girls would you want your
daughters to watch that video well I'll
I'll speak as a person who once upon a
time wasn't a father of two girls
um I see what they're doing and they're
they're providing a prescription for
basically men that are under attack in
modern society and I I think it's I
think it's pretty horrifying however
what's equally horrifying is there are
you know this is not one-sided there are
women that are living in this Fallen
World who do not have Godly foundations
who are playing into it as well so this
is not this is not a zero game
um but it's it's it's indicative of a
fallen world that lives without
Foundation that will be led to the most
base of our animal instincts and I think
they're providing a very you know
intricate plan on how to play and roam
and succeed in that construct that's the
construct of life we have and you know
what I it's not my construct and it's
not a construct that I want my daughters
to buy into or be a part of but it's a
construct but there's women that are
playing into that without Godly
foundations as well and that's the game
okay so let me give my feedback and then
we can go to the next Story number one
uh I I don't know why he makes that
video I would never make a video like
that to say how many virginities you
take per year etc etc if you date you
know and if you have a sister your
Dynamics changes in the way you view the
world you know because you're so
protective of your sister so in your
mind if you're afraid of God and you
have the fear of God you fear what you
do to girls one day is going to come
back and someone's going to do it to
your sister or they're going to do to
your kids so that fear of God is a very
powerful thing to have I had this in
since I was a kid so it messed with me a
lot because I had an older sister and
I'm super protective now
um for me my daughters are going to
watch that video smart I'm going to have
both of my girls watch that video when
they get to an age and I'm gonna say hey
check this out girls
here's a guy named Tristan okay I've
spent time with them I actually like
this guy and by the way if you're also
not too careful you will also like guys
like this because they're out there
because they're Charming they're sexy
they're attractive but their outcomes
are different outcomes so someone is
going to try to take your virginity away
from you okay you only get to say that
once God willing it's your choice and
it's somebody you love that maybe leads
to you getting married or you save
yourself that's a choice you got to make
as an individual and as a parent you got
to prepare them okay as they put them in
the right environment God all of those
things you got to do yourself so one
they're watching that video to know
exactly what some of the tactics may be
number two I think you know uh
strategies out there most men have no
clue on how to date a girl no clue on
how to date a girl there are strategies
on how to date a co-worker there are
strategies on how to date you know areas
What markets to Target heck there was a
documentary Wedding Crashers where you
can go you know and Target a few
minerals if you remember Will Ferrell
rocked the funerals right that was it I
watched a documentary many times some
lived it some watched it but to to you
know Neil uh what's the guy's name Neil
strong wrote the book The Game yeah him
and I were talking I'm at Harvard I'm
talking to the guy in 2015 I said Neil I
want to bring you on I'll never forget
what he said he says Pat I don't want to
talk about the book the game I said why
he says because because I'm actually
married right now with kids my life's
changed I actually never wanted him now
I'm embarrassed of writing that book
some words to you right so but but
here's the point the point is he may be
going through that face one day and he
may say good for him for us to expect
and look at Tristan and Andrew as their
Jesus and they walk on water that's not
my standard of anybody I learned a long
time ago if you have that standard of
anybody you'll be disappointed very
quickly but the amount of influence that
they're having out there on boys and
what they're doing if there isn't a
father figure that's teaching those
things kids are going to gravitate to
somebody like that like that that's
going to inspire them I think they're
doing more good for society than bad if
you ask me I think they're fighting to
fight and unfortunately sometimes the
people that we want to fight to fight
will never meet a hundred percent of
everybody's criterias never the people
who have the courage to go up against
the biggest bullies of all time were
never people you would have said I like
a hundred things out of 100 things that
this guy stands for no they're typically
very very complicated human beings that
have lived very weird lives that have
been tough lives that they have some
scars they have some Vengeance in them
but they're fearless and to get that
kind of fearlessness requires a pretty
shitty life to live to get to a point
like that some people that have lived a
very proper life mom and dad would marry
the entire time they were together they
were not grown in the streets my parents
got two divorces from each other for 20
years certain lives are creating
different kinds of human beings I don't
sit there and say that is the gold
standard on every single thing you
should do with your life I say yeah you
know what that's pretty crazy video to
make you know what if I was friends with
you at that time I would tell you what
are you doing making this video this
take this thing down this has been
isolated so here's what I hear that
you're saying you can correct me if I'm
wrong I hear you saying that the type of
behavior that he was encouraging and
training young men in and this is the
type of stuff that's behind their
paywall if you join their Hustler
University or whatever they call it so
you're saying that you would view that
as a threat to your daughters because
you're going to show them show this
video to your daughters in order to warn
them about young men who would take
advantage of them sexually by deceiving
them into thinking that they're cared
about I'm surrounded by players I mean I
but you view that as a threat to your
own children which means that you don't
view what Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate
are bringing to young men as something
positive because what they're doing is
they're training other young men to
behave like that yeah they do have an
incredible opportunity I I acknowledge
what you're saying they came from a hard
background and they've been financially
successful I would argue that they were
financially or financially successful
for immoral reasons I mean they ran a
pornography business that's not really
something to be proud of it's not
something that you want to inspire in
other young men is to run only fans
accounts not give the girls the
passwords manipulate them into staying
in the house I mean that's not really a
pause positive thing but if they if they
if this is what they're teaching to
young men then the next generation of
young men who may not be as wise as you
are and saying I don't put anybody on a
pedestal I don't view anyone as a savior
they do view these guys as a savior
because the only people it's the only
people that are telling them like yes
you have a valid grievance with your
masculinity being attacked we're gonna
have a we're gonna have a culture of
young men in 10 years who are
objectifying women using them and
modifying their bodies I think that's
good if I have a binary choice between
the current educational system
that's getting people to go from
traditional this point eight percent
than being part of the lgbtq party uh
the community we can say party already
whatever you want to call it it's a
party and you got Boomers is what two
percent then you got you know
Millennials is whatever then next one is
when then gents these are 21 yeah if
that indoctrine is turning one out of
five people kids to be part of lgbtq and
these guys are not I would much rather
have them listen to this guy just to be
fair with you can I make one quick Point
yeah so you got 20 seconds everything's
about you got 20 seconds because we got
to move on I got 15 minutes
evolving and getting better I would
argue that that video was done many many
years ago and I think they have evolved
their defense okay so you read the game
I read the game most guys will want to
read something like that to get more
women at some point you're going to
evolve I'll give one last thing I
started reading pbd's book over the week
choose your enemies wisely okay they
have chosen their enemies very wisely
and in many cases the enemies have
chosen them but Pat in the beginning of
the book talks about logic versus
emotion what is not the good emotions is
actually what these guys talk about and
it's the foundation of stoicism what is
not
good emotion is being sensitive
illogical weak-minded impulsive
irrational and just being a but
what is good emotion is having passion
stoicism being hyper obsessed with what
you want to accomplish being relentless
being powerful and having purpose and I
would argue that the Tates try to bring
out those types of emotions the good
emotions in men okay good let's go to
the next story here all right so which
one do we want to go to with the time
that we have left do we want to do new
some 20 an hour do we want to do the
sentence Bill Maher do we want to do
Gates uh McCarthy do we want to do
shocking number of Europeans on a number
of times to fly do we want to do Kelsey
take
okay then that's what we'll do we'll do
Taylor Swift and we'll do the Bowman guy
all right so Taylor Swift as the NFL
unnoticed as her economic dominance
spreads okay so page eight
um
so Taylor Swift had transcended her role
as a mega star and emerged as an
economic Powerhouse her uh I'm sorry you
want to read this part you want to look
for page eight I think it's important
for you to read this part I love the
article because you speak so it's an
Assyrian word but go ahead all right so
uh Taylor Swift has transcended her role
as a mega star and emerge as an economic
Powerhouse her eras tour which if you
are a Syrian you're listening has a
completely different meaning than what
the tour actually is we'll talk about
that later with resale tickets yo think
about this 3 800 for a average ticket
could generate uh 4.6 billion dollars in
consumer spending in the us alone uh the
Federal Reserve acknowledged Swift's
impact to local economies uh citing her
concerts at a catalyst for increased
Hotel Revenue in Philadelphia uh
additionally her upcoming eras tour uh
or erastor movie is expected to make a
hundred million dollar box office splash
bolstering the struggling uh Hollywood
industry Taylor Swift's appearance in
the NFL game between Kansas City and
Chicago Bears significantly boosted the
League's popularity despite the game's
one side outcome it drew 24.3 million
average viewers with an 8.1 increase in
female viewers in the 12 of the 17 year
old uh demographic female viewers and
like because Liz I want to know what you
guys opinions are so that that influence
that movement that bringing all the
eyeballs it's to go to the political
side she's obviously voiced her opinion
on on politics we all know where she
stands the guy that she's dating the
first thing he does when they start
dating he's like hey get your vax get
your shot get get your boot get get
everything I'm just it's it's it's funny
to me it's like you guys realize they're
gonna break up like I hope everybody out
there all the people that are just like
oh my God this is match made in heaven
it's not good it's gonna work it still
works forever but Pat I don't say that I
thought about it I really thought about
it you know the breakup song is gonna
have to do with the NFL you know she's
gonna sing a song that's gonna go you
fumbled me inside the end zone that's a
penalty you're now in the friend zone
screw the Chiefs like that's gonna be
the the when they break up what's over
the hell was that that was actually good
yeah and think about this and guys think
about this when she's done with him what
happens to all those viewers and the
taste of all these peoples in their
mouth of the NFL what happens what
happens to the mass exit of swifties
because when she leaves those swifties
are coming with her like you you know
what I mean they're gonna break up for
two reasons
um number one uh he's a fan of Andrew
taitless I mean he's a big strong
strapping dude he's actually uh one of
those masculine dudes that is a fan of
Tate so we'll see if that works out but
they're gonna work out uh or not work
out because of one main reason money
there's something called hypergamy women
like dating up so this might be fun
short term he's a fun cool football guy
he's worth 30 million she's worth 750
million yeah he'll be able to treat her
to dinner and take her out and treat her
nice and show her a good time
but he ain't flying around on private
jets he ain't traveling all around the
world with her he ain't got it like that
and I was 12 is Kelsey a stud the man
best tight end the league arguably No
Doubt this is a whole nother level big
time and I I know this from experience
to not get too personal one of my best
friends dated not dated married a girl
more famous than Taylor Swift okay Kim
Kardashian and let me tell you 50
million
eight one billion of course and at some
point those billionaire type women are
going to go after billionaire times yeah
but Liz you agree though I mean like
obviously this is all for politics and
you know the visual of it don't you
think like that isn't it kind of weird
that all this is happening she's opening
her mouth about politics he's telling
people to get the the new vaccine like
does it like do you see that my reaction
when I saw his vaccine ad was his
heart's gonna be broken by either the
shot or by her but it's an inevitable
conclusion yeah one way or the other one
way or the other at night I don't mean
not to credit whoever came up with that
joke I saw it on Twitter and yeah like
it was cracked me up listen Taylor Swift
is very interesting because she
obviously is outspoken about liberal
politics right leftist politics I think
she's pro-abortion I think she was
against she was against Marcia Blackburn
in Tennessee but the reason that her
eras tour is so incredibly successful
like who doesn't love Taylor Swift songs
sorry Gabriel I love you the reason it's
so successful is because while she
preaches feminism politically her entire
Bank of songs are actually
anti-feminists they speak to what young
women actually desire but are told that
they culturally shouldn't so it speaks
to true love getting married having a
family running away together fairy tales
this very actually family-centric
wholesome message in most of her songs
which is a contradiction of her personal
life and her politics but I think it's
very interesting because art culture
tells like 12 year olds to 17 year old
women you should go into stem that's the
only thing you should do don't focus on
having babies right now save that for a
long time go on birth control for 15
years do that freeze your eggs save them
but what young women actually want is
they want to fall in love they want to
be wives and mothers they might have
other other goals I mean I I do both
obviously but every young woman wants
that and I think it's really interesting
that she's such a liberal personally but
she's making her money off of like
traditions every woman wants that yeah
if I'm we're gonna wrap up because we we
couldn't hit other stores it's 1102. if
I'm the CMO of MLB Tom you know what
what I'm doing we're putting an entire
Campaign together for shohei Otani to
date Taylor Swift way too much eyeballs
away from the MLB and I don't appreciate
it we're going to create a breakup and
his next contract solves High pergame
yeah it should be like a season of The
Bachelorette but like professional
athletes which sport which League oh
that's hilarious
anyways uh take uh a list if you can
wrap it up and give us 30 seconds about
this book hide your children uh why you
wrote it what's in it and then we'll
wrap up the podcast yeah yeah you guys
can get it at hideyourchildrenbook.com
or wherever books are sold I wrote this
because I like most parents in the
country have been shocked at the
assaults on our children from critical
race Theory to transgender ideology to
1619 project and I wondered who's behind
this where's this coming from what's
their goal so I dug into that and the
first half of this book I name the names
of the people in the organizations that
are behind each one of those attacks
just like the queer Theory stuff we
talked about and the second half of the
book I actually provide a solution which
is different than the Republican party
it's actually critique of the Republican
party because I think we've been
fighting very poorly against these
cultural forces for the last couple
decades so I propose a different
solution for how we can actually start
winning for once and protect our kids I
love it guys go order the book we'll put
the link below just came out a week ago
hide your children exposing the Marxist
behind the attack on America's kids take
care like I said one thing too uh Tampa
I'm coming to Tampa Improv October 18th
for one night one show oh my God improv
is that your birthday can you fly I love
it I may join you so October 18th the
second link is in my on my Instagram uh
my bio sick love it okay guys take care
everybody we'll do this again are we
doing anything Thursday or Thursday and
Coulter and then on Friday we have Tim
pool and Jimmy door joining us Friday or
Saturday Saturday I'm sorry Saturday
morning so Jimmy Durant yes sir that
should be interesting okay take
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
this was great